[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the great pleasure of sitting today with
dr
jordan b peterson he is an author
a youtube lecturer and professor of
psychology at the university
of toronto welcome jordan good to see
you
thanks for the invitation well it's very
good to see you sir
um i should probably tell people in our
audience uh
that there might be some slight
strangeness about this
discussion because you and i have had a
recent one on your channel which is not
yet out and so in some sense we are
picking up a discussion
in motion that those who are watching
will not have
yet seen in any case we talk in in that
one about your
uh your absence from the scene and how
grateful i am to see you
uh back at it so i won't recover that
territory here
i should say that this uh discussion
between you and me is taking place
on the occasion of the publication of
your
new book yes book is called beyond order
12 more rules for life
i should tell our listeners that i have
not read it you sent me a copy but it
got hung up in customs
um but anyway i'm very excited to see it
and i think many others will be
as well do you want to say anything
about the book well i have it here
perfect as you said it's out today um
it's making the scene i guess it's
number one in australia and number two
which is quite nice
i've and 12 rules is number five
so that's was kind of remarkable to see
today and so thank you to all the people
in australia who are reading me i
appreciate that very much
i hope people find the book useful
i tried to put as much care into it as i
put into the first book and
i hope that's reflected in in the book
and i hope they make a nice balanced
package
the first one concentrates more on
excesses of chaos
associated with uncertainty and the
unexpected i suppose
and the second one concentrates more on
the danger of excess
order and those are the two great
dangers i think
great two of the greatest dangers the
pathology of social
structures and and the danger of
everything that we don't understand
and so those are two of the major things
that people have to manage in life
archetypally speaking universally
speaking
and so that's the basis for the books
now
obviously this is the first 24 rules
for life that you came up with i know
you generated a long list
initially when you started on the
project
presumably people should read both of
those books if they're interested in
your top 24
is there a reason that they should read
the first
one before reading the second one or
i hope not i didn't write them that way
i think that they complement each other
so
if you read both of them both of them
are better
but i designed each of them to stand on
their own
so and i i hope they do that
each of the chapters as well i would say
so
there's a chapter dedicated to each rule
also stands on its own but
they are thematically linked and they
play on each other so
hopefully the whole is greater than the
sum of the parts
that's the that's the whole point of
writing a book
and hypothetically i managed that
and uh i should say that these are not
the only two books you've written
you also famously at this point
wrote maps of meaning much earlier in
your career
a very different style of book
i would say more
analytical and less dedicated to
providing people uh useful advice on how
to
to work through the the various trials
and tribulations of life do you want to
say anything about
about it well
i wrote it obviously to communicate with
people but i wouldn't say that was my
primary goal
um although perhaps that should be the
primary goal of an author
i wrote it to figure something out you
know it was
it was an investigation and writing is a
protracted form of thinking and the
advantage to writing
as thinking is that you writing makes
you smarter than
you are without the paper and pencil or
without the computer
especially the computer because the
computer can enable you to edit
editing has become effortless in some
sense
back when you use paper and pencil there
was a tremendous amount of labor
involved in editing
not not just mental labor obviously
reconfiguring the ideas but
actual muscular
energy or even with a typewriter it was
very difficult to
produce sequential drafts you have to
retype whole pages or
or it would become an unreadable mess
but with a computer
you can incrementally improve
indefinitely
and so you can have a very long
discussion with yourself
and i took full advantage of that when i
wrote maps of meaning
and i was trying to i was trying to
account for malevolence of the genocidal
sort i suppose at the individual level
motivation for
for genocide um and then to also try to
outline how that might be avoided
given that it's a pronounced human
propensity
far more pronounced than we like to
admit and
i i spent 15 years thinking about that
and that was maps of meaning it's a very
difficult book
it was difficult to write i found it
difficult to
read when i re when i've reread it there
are chapters that i really have to think
hard about to
to to fully understand
even though i wrote them they it's
because i stretched myself to my
intellectual limits
maybe beyond in some ways um all of the
many of the ideas that i developed in 12
rules for life and in beyond order
stem from maps of meaning so and
certainly much of what i've done in my
career
as a lecturer owes its success
to the the 15 years of three-hour days
roughly speaking that i put in on that
book and so it was an unbelievably
useful exercise
uh so
i don't know if you'll uh recall and i
admit i'm
not certain of what the exact scope was
but you and i have discussed before
the fact that my very first evolutionary
project when i was an undergraduate
working for bob trivers
or working with bob trivers i did a
project in which i analyzed
the holocaust through an evolutionary
lens and
effectively reached the conclusion that
these
that um that hitler was a monster but
that he was a rational
monster and that it is very important
for us to understand what that means
that this was too easily dismissed as
insanity rather than
depravity of a recognizable kind
and yes well it's important to give the
devil his due
and when you when you discount something
of that magnitude
you risk failing to understand it you
think of it as
a one-off in some sense and
that may be true although it's not as if
genocidal acts are one-offs
they're very common unfortunately
you can make a strong case that there
was something particularly egregious
about the holocaust
although there were 20th century
catastrophes that were
arguably of of of
comparable horror if you want to
compare dare to compare horrors
but terrible things happened in maui's
china and in cambodia and in
the soviet union and perhaps
all of that wasn't undertaken with the
blood blood curdling efficiency of the
third reich
that's part of what makes that story
uniquely horrible but i i i agree with
you that
discounting it as a form of
psychopathology
is not very helpful especially when you
think that there was
a whole country involved and more than
that really
so yes i think um
a i do think there was something special
about the third reich
but it was a variation on a theme that
is much
less unique and that in some sense
is now a problem because um
in my opinion the only way to prevent
these things from continuing to happen
is to
understand what it is in human nature
that causes them
and that in fact um
well all right let's start with the
dangerous argument shall we
god yeah here let me
let me uh talk by analogy um
let us just say that all of us
because for very for many reasons are
likely
the descendants of uh
women who were raped at some point in
history
and we likely all carry the genetic
capacity
to engage in it as a result but
most men that i spend time with i
believe are actually not
capable of this and they're not
incapable of it
because they're genetically incapable
they're incapable of it because
development
took that option off the table and that
there are great many things
in human nature that are like this
things that when we are born
the capacity exists and then a
proper upbringing and an environment
that does not reinforce these things or
better
makes them disgusting to us takes them
off the uh the list of possibilities
and i believe that genocide let me let
me
add something to that please you tell me
what you think
well there's there's two things i think
that
take it off the table one
might be developmental history and and
so you might say that
there could be a biological tendency and
if it isn't
encouraged reinforced or even if it's
punished
out of existence through inattention
even
i won't pay attention to you if you do
that or i'll punish you outright if you
do it one way or another
it can't develop but then i would also
say that
in a functioning society the
eliciting conditions for that behavior
are also
unlikely to arise i mean you you see
mass rape very frequently in wartime
and it it is quite unlike normal male
sexual behavior in the context of an
intimate relationship partly because
it's often
at least somewhat public which makes it
unique because sexual activity among
intimate partners is generally private
but in wartime it can be public and
so i would say that we protect ourselves
against that biological propensity that
genetic propensity
partly through socialization by by
bringing aggression under control
especially in its sexual elements but
also by structuring our society so that
we never allow ourselves to go somewhere
where those motivations are likely to
emerge and also where they wouldn't be
immediately punished out of existence
but that can happen i think you see
those sorts of things happen
in the midst of riots for example where
you know a law-abiding person a
generally law-abiding person will get
caught up in the chaotic frenzy and find
themselves
doing things that they had perhaps never
done before
i would like to think that it's a matter
of socialization and a matter of
regulation by conscience but i do think
that a fair bit of it is also
brought under control by the stability
and relative benevolence of the social
surround
well i think those two things uh
obviously fit well together now let me
give you let me give you an example
sure from the chimps so chimps
especially the adolescent males will go
on what are essentially
border patrol uh
they'll patrol the borders of their
territories and there's usually a couple
of them three four
five a group a small group and sometimes
a female or two but generally adolescent
males
if they come across uh a chimp a
mailchimp from
another troop or
if it could be one or a couple they have
to outnumber them generally
they'll often react extremely
aggressively
and really aggression without control so
chimps are hunters and they'll hunt
colabus monkeys for example which are
about 40 pounds if i remember correctly
and they tear them from limb to limb and
sometimes they'll eat them when they're
alive and they're screaming away and
that doesn't inhibit them and then when
they attack
foreign chimps there also doesn't seem
to be any inhibition of aggression
whatsoever it's it's
it's it's there in its full array
then but in their own troops they engage
in dominance disputes and those will
often escalate
but the rest of the troop gets upset and
tends to regulate it
and so that's it's looking at that sort
of thing that makes me
afraid that it isn't so much
socialization as it is
our attempt to ensure that we always
maintain ourselves
in peaceful circumstances and we never
depart from those
places not if we can help it so
hopefully socialization also matters
well i would argue
that these two things work together that
you have a very dangerous possibility
and that um by reducing the amount of
flammable material around and reducing
the care with which one plays with
the flame the likelihood of
a fire out of control is reduced and
that if you take away either one of
these things it it goes up
spectacularly with respect to the
question of
of rape i would say you have the added
feature that in order for a man
to rape a woman he has to be turned on
and so in some sense there's an extra
protection on the system that a
a a man who has grown up as a boy in an
environment that
caused the idea of rape to become
disgusting to him
will not be uh capable of the act
hopefully
so we don't have that in the case of
something like genocide
i believe we do need to make all of the
various thought processes that result in
warfare and genocide disgusting
so that people do not engage in these
behaviors
and you know if we don't
i suspect we will see exactly what we
are seeing now which is people playing
with the very tropes that create
this impulse not realizing that in some
sense
there is a program uh
latent within humans that when activated
creates exactly
the the discontinuous kind of behavior
that you see
in in chimpanzees when they encounter
rival males well i think in the human
case it's actually
the chimps the chimp analogy is is
pretty brutal
but chimpanzees are certainly exceeded
in their capacity for brutality by human
beings
and that's partly because
i think it's partly because and this
it took me a long time to think this
through and i do outline it in
in all three of my books um
there's a scene in genesis where people
become self-conscious their eyes are
open and virtually at the same time so
the story goes
they become capable of the knowledge of
good and evil
and it's a very mysterious story but
after thinking about it literally for a
decade or so
i i started to understand i think that
it's a story about so what happens is
people become self-conscious
they become aware of their nakedness and
they become aware of good and evil they
also become aware of their
uh destiny they're destined to work
and work is something that's relatively
unique to human beings if if you think
about it as
uh delay of gratification conscious
delay of gratification
i'll give up something now which is a
sacrifice
in order to obtain something of more
value in the future that that's one of
the
outstanding discoveries of of of
humankind
the emphasis on sacrifice in the old
testament for example i think is a
is is a it's a historical
portrayal a quasi-historical portrayal
of the emergence of the idea of
sacrifice which i believe was first
acted out
before it was understood psychologically
or explicitly so you imagine
you know you think i do think in an
evolutionary manner
and you know i i take seriously the fact
that
life has been around for three and a
half billion years and that there's been
mammals for 60 million and
you know it's been seven or eight since
we split from our shared ancestor with
chimps
that's a very long period of time over
that period of time
human beings realized that they could
let go of something in the present and
gain something in the future
and there's that's and but that
there's no way you don't leap from
the complete lack of knowledge of that
fact among chimpanzees to the
explicit ability to state it as a set of
propositions
without an insanely long developmental
history
in between those two points and human
beings
learned over time that those who let go
in the
present at least under some conditions
were much more likely to be
popular let's say with their peers
because if i'm a hunter for example i
could share with you
and store up my goods in the form of the
favor that you now
owed me which is an extremely effective
way of storing food
and a very strange way of storing it we
learned over time that people who were
able to do that were more likely to
survive they made better mates and
and after that only long after that were
we able to derive that
as a principle anyways back to back to
uh
having our eyes opened when we became
self-conscious we
became aware of the future along with
our awareness of the future
came awareness of our own fundamental
mortality and fragility because that's
associated with the discovery of the
future
that also enabled us to put things off
until the future all those things happen
at once
the thing about human beings that makes
us so unbelievably vicious is that once
i'm aware of my own fragility
deeply aware of that i can capitalize on
that
because i can understand that what will
hurt me
will also hurt you and that means i can
start to make an
art out of pain animals you know
at their worst they're predatory in in a
brutal manner
but human beings go way past that in
their capacity for destruction
and it isn't only that the the capacity
that we have because we are
aware of our own fragility and so can
artfully use that awareness on others
it's also that we have motivations that
animals don't have too like
very complex motivations of revenge and
resentment
and they're very very very dark dark
motivations and i think part of the
reason it's so difficult for us to
understand
our own behavior in relationship to
events like
like the holocaust is that to really
understand that you have to look in
places that are
so dark that looking there is
is in itself virtually traumatic
and so people don't and i understand why
but
i don't think we have that luxury
unfortunately
i would say that exactly we don't have
the luxury and it's not that everybody
needs to look deeply into those dark
places but we need to agree that it has
to be done
that people who are capable of figuring
out what's there have to be
licensed to do it and uh we have to
avoid demonizing them
for uh thinking about it and discussing
it but i want to go back a little bit
um a lot of what you say resonates with
me here
i suspect the answer with respect to
what animals do and don't do
is um more nuanced than
than your thinking so for example i can
easily come up with several examples
um from various species
of what appears to be an impulse toward
delayed gratification
i don't think well i know it's there in
its nascent form and
and you certainly see it acted out um
i don't i mean it's built into animals
like
insects like bees for example it's built
into beavers
um you see i think you see instinctual
there's instincts that mimic delay of
gratification
and i do think it's there in its nascent
form
i mean like languages for example in
chimpanzees they can get
some distance with language although not
very far
you know it's ver there's virtually
nothing that you see in human beings
that you can't see echoes of in other
animals
but but you know at some point a degree
a difference in quantity say makes a
difference in quality and
and the self-conscious emotions are
developed to a very high degree
you see elephants for example seem to
have some sense of death
from what i've been able to understand
they do
return i think there are reliable
reports of them returning to places
where
a close relative of theirs had died and
moving the bones and that sort of thing
and they seemed to grieve and i've seen
grief in my pets
or what it certainly appears to be grief
um but
you know the the the certain knowledge
that your life is finite and so is
everyone else's
that seems to me to be uniquely human
and it's certainly uniquely human to be
able to state it as an explicit
proposition
yes i think that's very frequently where
the line is
there's no question in my mind that we
have clear evidence
of grief in uh
dogs in chimps in gorillas
in elephants in toothed whales
probably baleen whales we've seen it
and there's also no doubt in my mind
that in some of those cases
there is an element of what we would
call consciousness
involved but the thing that is so
special about humans
is the degree of elaboration of
consciousness
and the degree to which it is not
confined to individual skulls
that's to say our ability to transmit
abstract ideas between
skulls through language allows us
to actually share a consciousness which
is something i
uh i believe that we do in the most
literal sense and i believe is actually
the um the fundamental rudiment of
consciousness
and that unfortunately we've we've
bought the job of studying it because we
take
individual consciousness uh to be
primary when in fact it is
secondary well i'm i'm of the
line of the animal investigators let's
say that
you know there's this injunction that's
frequently
delivered to people who study animals
that you should be careful of
anthropomorphizing
but i don't really like that idea i
think that
you should assume continuity unless
there's evidence to the contrary and
i think that's even true of
consciousness i mean you know
people reflexively assume that
consciousness
is a consequence of the development of
the higher order brain centers the
neocortex the prefrontal cortex and all
of that but
you can lose an awful lot of cortical
territory and still
maintain consciousness so i think
consciousness is i mean it's very
difficult to pin down exactly what it is
there's a phenomenological aspect to it
which is extraordinarily mysterious the
fact that
experience exists is almost
indistinguishable from the idea that
being itself exists and so it's a very
deep idea
but i think that consciousness is an
ancient phenomena
elaborated self-conscious that's
linguistic that's a different story that
seems to be something that's
well comparatively new and also
comparatively unique
it's at least it's at least unique in
the degree
that it allows us to work in conscious
space
and innovate so the delayed
gratification point that you were making
earlier
it is certainly true that um
you know a squirrel caching acorns
is involved in something that is clearly
reflective
of an instinct as you say towards
delayed gratification
we don't know how much the squirrel
knows about it but we
humans can um innovate
we can decide that our ultimate
objective is something deep in the
future and we can
in we can link together many different
costs that we might be willing to pay in
the short term
in order to get there and do a very
elaborate version of
what a uh a squirrel or salmon or any
one of a number of creatures do in a
rudimentary
form but the degree to which that is
distinct is so substantial
that in some sense it's its own category
yes yes well and and we can also reflect
on it as you're doing
and i think the critical apart from the
ability to reflect on it
the critical element there is that we
can delay gratification
in a way that no other human being in
our ancestral chain has ever delayed
gratification whereas
squirrel a and squirrel offspring b
pretty much do exactly the same thing
and that's part of the innovation
idea and if they do innovate that's
usually a consequence of difference in
environment between squirrels rather
than any
innovative capacity that's inherent to
the squirrel that's even true of
chimpanzees as far as i can tell
you know there is some variation in tool
use but i think the simplest explanation
for that is well there's
variation in environment so those things
that offer them to the
rudimentary to themselves to the
rudimentary tool using capacity of the
chimp vary from
environment to environment that's the
innovation
because it has to be that way to my way
of thinking because
you know because of compound interest
you don't need much innovative capacity
for it to become
explosive very very rapidly on the
evolutionary time scale like if you
could
if a chimp could innovate one tenth of
one percent a year
it would only be let's say a million
years before there was an advanced
chimpanzee society
and we don't see that so the the the
evidence is well the innovation doesn't
occur
or if it does it's certainly not
cumulative it can't be transmitted
and that's also something of crucial
importance or it exists in a
bounded context where it pays less and
less basically i would argue
you would i mean a you do see roughly
what you're describing in the six
million year trajectory from
our our split from chimpanzee ancestors
um you know we have seen a uh we have
seen several
cumulative booms right it's not a
perfectly consistent
rate but there has been an elaboration
of capacity and in fact
the best argument for why our lineage
looks different
is that we achieved something that my
phd advisor called ecological dominance
which is
the state at which it is competition
with other members of your species that
is the strongest determinant of your
evolutionary success
at which point you have an arms race and
so basically human capacity for thought
uh was built up as one group competed
against another and
innovated against another which of
course would make tremendous use of
language as a conduit between
consciousnesses
in order to facilitate um adaptation
so in the chimp case i would argue the
very limited capacity to transmit
abstract
ideas between chimps is
running up against the degree to which
one can escape
the uh the limits of the ecological
context in which the chimp finds itself
so um there's the capacity for
cumulative culture
even in chimps but its ability to
extract more and more from the world is
limited by
the ecological context
so i i i know something that that i'd
like to talk to you about
i i have some evolutionary ideas i've
been wrestling with these for a long
time about the origins
of i suppose the origins of religious
ideas the evolutionary origins of
religious ideas
um and so i'd like to run those by you a
little bit can i
can i put you on pause this uh it
certainly can you uh
you reminded me of what i wanted to talk
to you about
uh as a result of what you were saying
in that last
segment okay and it is exactly on this
topic so we are we are converging here
so my point was going to be that
actually
belief in something like an afterlife
is it's consistent at least with the
hypothesis that evolution
is extending the possible
if gratification can be delayed
gratification can be delayed
till after death right that in effect by
building an afterlife on which
you reflect during your actual life one
can
effectively reschedule the rewards
such that it is fine by you to pay a
cost that you are not repaid in life
thinking that it will be repaid later
and in some sense
it is repaid but not in the form that
the mythology would tell us it's repaid
in the form
of your descendants the carriers of your
genes
being well positioned in their future
going forward and so
uh to see it's ideas like that that that
motivated at least in part the
discussions that i had with sam harris
because that's a really good example
assuming that it's valid
and it might be and it might not be like
we can't tell
um that's that's an idea
let's say your your proposition is
that's an idea that in some sense is
objectively false
but evolutionarily true metaphorically
true but literally false
yes yes but but but because it
it it furthers adaptation and it's
it's at some point it's difficult to
at some point you have to make it
distinct it's difficult to draw a
distinction between
truth as it's uh defined pragmatically
and on the darwinian landscape and truth
as it's defined
when you're when your concern is the
nature of the objective world and
and that that was really at the core of
the discussion that i wanted to
continually have with sam and i think
did have
with some degree of success um
so um i i agree with what you just said
and the
the difficult point sometimes i can make
this point
to the scientifically minded
about the phenomenon of religious
mythology
it becomes very difficult to make the
reverse point which i heard you
just make there which is actually if you
look at the way we do science
effectively we start out with a large
uh fraction of a model that we have for
some phenomenon
and the large fraction is effectively
metaphorically true literally false it's
good enough in order to operate in the
space but it's not
accurate if you pursue the phenomenology
and over time what you get is models
that contain
less and less of that metaphorical truth
and are closer and closer
to literal laboratory truth you never
get to zero
right as far as we know but the fact
that we get better
causes us not to realize that it was in
some sense
an analog of the instinct
to religious faith that effectively
provides
the faith to explore yeah that was
exactly young's argument about the
derivation of science from alchemy
no interesting well it's exactly that
argument is that
for from the union perspective the
alchemists were possessed by a
and the fantasy was that the redemptive
substance could be found in the bowels
of matter
in base matter and the perfection of
matter would
reveal the redemptive substance and
and now the reason that jung insisted
upon that was because he was trying to
account for
why people became motivated to pursue
pursue the painstaking behaviors and
observations that
made up empirical science which may not
be motivationally
significant in and of themselves they
have to be associated with something
that is of motivational significance
so it was a redemptive fantasy and
that's
also partly what convinced me that the
scientific enterprise is in some sense
inerratically nested inside a narrative
um and the narrative is well if we
explore the
material world the objective material
world that that will be of
benefit to all of us and that's not a
scientific proposition that's
that's the an a priory statement of
faith
that motivates everything that
constitutes the scientific enterprise
and so that's another example of the
of the same thing um let let me i've
been thinking about the development of
the idea of the hero
and i suppose the like the the archetype
of the hero the
the the hero doesn't go any farther than
the messianic story
by definition i would say that's sort of
where it
where it tops out and so how might have
that evolved
well it seems to me that
it's a consequence of us living in in
hierarchies
and we tend to think of hierarchies as
hierarchies of power especially when
we're looking at the animal kingdom
although with chimpanzees
that's and even other animals that's
that's it's not clear that that's the
case at all
that the wall has shown that
primatologists have shown quite clearly
that
chimpanzee troops are a lot more stable
when the dominant male because it is a
patriarchy
chimpanzees are essentially a
patriarchal society
if the if the alpha male is cooperative
and generous
and kind to the females and their
offspring there's a lot less
internal conflict inside the troop and
there's a higher probability that the
guy in charge is going to stay in charge
and so what that implies is that
strongly implies is that
the the hierarchy that's predicated on
good faith game playing reciprocal game
playing
and reciprocity is more stable even
biologically speaking than one that's
based on nature red in tooth and claw
and then you can imagine so then take it
another step so imagine you have a
hierarchy
and the most effective way of moving up
that hierarchy across
time so that would be something that's
stable across multiple
landscapes of selection is whatever
moves you up the hierarchy
and the reason that that's
that benefits fitness is because the
females are more likely to mate with
the the more the the males that array
themselves
near the top of the hierarchy and so
then imagine that
we've been in these hierarchies forever
and
we've observed successful behavior and
have an instinct to admire it because
that instinct to admire it facilitates
mimicry
and then imagine that we've learned to
mimic multiple aspects of behavior
that are associated with reciprocity and
fair play that move people up competence
hierarchies
and so we've evolved our morality has
actually evolved
to match biologically what's being
demanded by the
social hierarchy and then we abstract
out of that
the ideal which is
that pattern of behavior that moves you
across the largest number of dominance
hierarchies
and that actually exists in our
imagination as a latent religious symbol
and then that's filled up by narrative
constantly refilled and filled
and the ultimate exemplar of that has
religious power
and it and the r that that inspires is
if you're thinking about it biologically
is the manifestation of the instinct to
imitate
and then you think okay then you can
take that one step farther if that's
true and i
believe me i'd welcome a critique
because if there's something wrong with
that idea i'd really like to know it
um
that that ideal does in fact
end up being the most effective way to
live
in the broadest possible sense and so
it's valid and then you might ask well
is it objectively valid and
that's a very difficult thing to say
because generally
we're not very good at looking at
complex patterns as objective reality we
tend to have to reduce things to the
material substrate
and we can get a grip on what's
materially true as we become more and
more reductionistic
but at those higher levels of
abstraction you know like
hierarchies have been around for a very
very long time
it's not unreasonable to assume that
there's a characteristic pattern of
behavior
that moves you up or down the hierarchy
it's not unrealistic to assume that we
would be able to note
when we're partaking of that or
observing it or violating it
that's conscience as far as i can tell
and
there it isn't unreasonable to note that
our perceptions of that might be
accurate now what that means
metaphysically
see i don't understand that either
because human beings are unbelievably
complicated
we have the most complicated nervous
systems that there are
our brains are the most complex
structures that we know of
except for other brains so we are the
most complex thing that we know of
and so we're a pinnacle of sorts and i'm
not saying that evolution is
driving towards that pinnacle but in
terms of cognitive elaboration it has
so is the ideal form of that complaint
is it unreasonable to propose that the
ideal form of that complexity
is divine the universe has been aiming
at it since day one in some
sense well so the universe has not been
aiming at it
as far as i can tell what it does is
tend
towards something it tends toward a kind
of stability and what you're arguing
i hear some things in it well i didn't
want to smuggle in a tube over
teleology but you know here we are and
everything
you know we we actually did emerge so
and it's not it's not obvious what to
make of that may it could have been
otherwise
you can say that but it wasn't so
right so so here we are and i think you
know what i what i get from what you're
saying and
the part i agree with is that
a i think people like both you and me
are
too used to having to argue that
these patterns are adaptive
and therefore entitled to a whole host
of defenses that they are not
uh generally given or at least
they are entitled to leeway to be
evaluated on honorable
grounds rather than uh castigated for
the fact that they don't match up with
experiment or something along those
lines
i do think or desire well that's that's
where i'm going next
is we the thing that i don't hear
in what you're saying the bitter pill
here is that ultimately
or maybe not i won't say ultimately but
historically
the genes have been in charge every step
of the way
that is to say all of the stuff that we
do above the gene level
all of the cultural stuff all of the
conscious stuff has been in service
of the genes and that's unfortunate
but but no there is a flaw in that i
thought about that
well look in human beings increasingly
consciousness structures the mechanism
that selects the genes
so here's an example let's say
i'll see if i can get this right
so imagine for example that that you
live in a hunter-gatherer troop
and you have a great hunter in your
midst
and he's great for two reasons one is
that he can hunt but the other reason is
that he shares
and so that makes him a really great
hunter and so you elevate his status now
you
you elevate his status it's like you all
vote all the men
vote here's the good guy he's he's on
top
now the price you pay for that is a
reduction at least on one level of your
own biological fitness because by
elevating him up the hierarchy you
increase the probability that he's going
to be chosen as a mate
now the benefit of that however is that
you know you get to eat and you don't
die
so but but my point here is is that
by that continual voting on what
constitutes competence and the
arrangement of those hierarchies
our conscious minds have structured the
landscape that
actually selects so the so men vote on
which
men are likely to mate and then the
women
compete for access to that victor and so
both men and women
are behaving in a manner that privileges
certain kinds of genetic
manifestations and so the consciousness
is shaping the genes
as much as the genes are shaping the
consciousness
the consciousness is in control of the
behavior
but it is subservient to the objective
of the genes and unfortunately
i think your the situation is that
you've been
handed a feeble toolkit by
evolutionary biologists and are trying
to make sense of the world as if it was
higher quality than it is so i don't
want to drag
uh you or our viewers
too deeply into the weeds here but my
claim is that
my field is divided between two camps
that are
incorrect one camp are the kin
selectionists
right people who view this as narrowly
genetic
these are my intellectual ancestors and
the other group
are the group selectionists who have
understood something else
which is that essentially
altruism pays and there are certain
places you can stand that it appears
that that is a driving evolutionary
force whereas mathematically
it is very difficult to make a robust
model of this sort at least not a
realistic one
my point would be the kin selectionists
have understood one part of the logic
correctly but they've instantiated it
too narrowly
the group selectionists have found a
fiction but just as we were describing
15 minutes ago that fiction has actually
given them license to explore a very
fertile piece of evolutionary territory
which is
the landscape of cultural evolution
right
cultural evolution does not make a
tremendous amount of sense
through the narrowest kin selected lens
it makes a great deal of sense through
the
group selected lens but the gateway is
fictional
and so i think you have for me you have
to bring that down to earth more before
i can completely follow what what you're
yeah i'm going to harass you about
critiquing my specific point after that
anyway okay good
so i'm trying to follow but i i put some
examples would probably help me
make sure i'm following you let's take
your example and let's put it into what
i think the right way of resolving
this conflict in evolutionary biology is
so
i would argue that the right way of
viewing this is something called
lineage selection now a lineage
is an individual and all of that
individual is descendants
okay and my point is that is actually
a valid target of evolution
lineages can evolve just the same way
individuals can
evolve so we can see adaptation at the
lineage level
which will look like if you don't pay
close enough attention to what you're
looking at it may look like group
evolution
which is in part why the group
selectionists have gotten themselves
confused
but here's the point let's take your
hunter-gatherer
band and the case of
the individual male who is an excellent
hunter
and is also valued by
his male companions because
he shares and therefore his status in
the group
provides some increased likelihood of
mating which could be taken as an
evolutionary loss
from the point of view of his male
competitors inside of his band
but i would argue isn't one and the
reason is this
let's think about this band if everybody
took a narrow view
of their own contribution to the next
generation
right if all they did if all the males
did was try to leave as many genes in
the next generation as possible
by whatever means necessary right a
that's a band
full of conflict right now
if we look across the larger landscape
all of the bands of hunter-gatherers
how much does the competition between
two individuals within one
band over mates affect how many copies
of their genes
are on that larger landscape and the
answer is
almost not at all right that is to say
you can have 10 offspring to some other
individual's two right and you might
think
that you'd beaten him by a factor of
five but there are two problems with
this
one if you are closely related to him
then a lot of what we narrowly and the
kinselect
the traditional kinselected view would
regard as a loss to you is actually
insignificant compared to the larger
landscape
but the other thing is if your band
blinks out of existence five generations
down the road
taking all of your great great great
great
grand offspring right
if it takes all those people with him
then
you have not succeeded the advantage you
got within one generation is completely
erased
by the loss of the population within
which you were embedded
so the point is if we really understood
the mindset
of the individual in rational
evolutionary terms we would understand
that they
in some sense will be built they will be
wired and programmed to behave in such a
way
both to advance their own genetic
interests and to protect the long-term
uh population well-being that allows
those genes to circulate
right they will effectively be
protecting a gene pool now the group
selectionists will jump and they will
say aha
you've done it you've said that groups
are valid and i will say no
it is not the group it is a lineage it
is the lineage protecting itself
through the individual that is
responsible for the adaptation here
you can dismiss it as a group but that's
like that's like
saying um that uh i threw a frisbee
what practical difference what practical
difference do you think that makes
in relationship to what are the
implications of that view compared to
the implications of group selection
viewpoint
well they're subtly distinct
but i would argue in the end decisive so
for example
if you take the group selection view and
you do not recognize the
game theoretic instability at its core
then you may struggle to find a
formulation of
marxism for example that realizes the
full benefits of human cooperation
not realizing that the structure you
build will be inherently
unstable and that you have to actually
correct for that instability
which will either happen through
brutality which you don't want
right or you will have to architect
something much
closer to what eleanor ostrom discovered
in her nobel prize
winning work about the way indigenous
peoples
do this very job so
i guess the point is the
group selection i would argue is a
temporary misunderstanding
of lineage selection but it does a good
enough
job to allow those who are involved in
thinking
in a group selected way to see human
cultural evolution for what it is
and that's where the payoff comes and so
my point is we can now go back
having found human cultural evolution
which is where the heavy lifting is done
we can now go back and correct the
group selected viewpoint and we can make
it rigorous
by looking at it as a lineage phenomenon
not a group phenomenon
and we have then a continuous
understanding which then
i we've gotten super complicated here
and i wish we hadn't but
i will point out though that the upshot
of this from my perspective
is the genes have been in charge
all along they have acted through
consciousness
they have acted through culture but
those things have been subordinate to
genetic objectives
but now that we have consciousness we
can look
at what it is that genes would have us
do and we can actually
take them out of that control position
and we must
because they contain things like
programs for genocide and warfare
that we must sideline if we're going to
survive so
having arrived at an understanding of
what we are actually built for
we now have to turn the tables on the
genes which is not easy but i also don't
think it's impossible
okay so i'm going to branch out two ways
there i
there i don't i
there's no objections to the argument
that you laid out
come come into my mind and it's it's
obviously something you've thought about
a lot and
i can't spin up hypothesis about lineage
selection versus group selection
sort of on the cuff i would say however
that
it isn't clear to me how that argument
independent of its validity is related
to my original proposition
that um
it's it's misleading in some sense to
think of the genes
more in charge than the consciousness
they're looping with one another because
the
because consciousness is in fact making
choices about
what constitutes those that will be
elected to the status of more likely
maters
and so that that doesn't have any
detrimental effect as far as i'm
concerned on the idea of genetic
i'm not trying to devalue the power of
genes across time at all but
if consciousness is selecting the
mechanism that selects
it's definitely altering
the probability that genes are going to
propagate against across time i would
say your lineage argument in some sense
actually
likely makes that case more strongly
because
look one of the things i outlined in
beyond order i touched on it a little
bit in
in the previous book was the idea that
you know some an action you undertake an
action
to to to to uh to gain a particular goal
in a particular framework of time
so all of your actions are bounded in
space and time
you don't want it to take forever and
you don't want it to occupy everywhere
right so
you're you're operating locally but you
have to operate locally in a way
this is like the lineage idea in a way
that doesn't disturb your next local
action or the one after that
you have to think about your action now
its consequences
immediately its consequences in a day a
week a month a year
and that shades off forever and so
an optimal action is one that takes you
where you want to go now but doesn't
interfere
with your ability to get to where you
want to go in the future or maybe even
makes that
easier and so you could say
we're we're sophisticated enough so that
we not only look for patterns of
behavior
to admire that work now but we look for
patterns of behavior that work now in a
way that isn't compromising the future
and
that's why for example i think that we
admire and track
reciprocity and that's obviously
something you're interested in as
someone who worked with trivers
we track reciprocity unbelievably well
and i would say that's at least in part
because
reciprocity is
a game that sustains itself across time
and that's actually a place where
you can see our eye to the future
operating
if i do you a favor and you don't return
it you're not trustworthy over the long
run
i can't rely on you and so i'm not going
to
afford you any benefits evolutionarily
or other
otherwise so any anything
any flaws in that that you see no i
would say that
there's another rung to that ladder so
uh as an undergraduate i worked with
trivers
um and uh reciprocity was
obviously uh a key feature of his
contribution to the field
my graduate advisor dick alexander
contributed the idea of
indirect reciprocity in which typically
mediated through things like reputation
it does not have to be repaid by the
individual for whom you've done the
service and of course this
actually underlies the evolution of of
economic systems and
and the like um but
i want to go back to the question you
asked me about um
whether or not the genes are not in fact
in some ways subject to
the the consciousness there's a limited
way in which that is true
clearly the genes are
exists in an environment in which the
consciousness has a great deal of say
over what the genes get to do
but here's the problem let's take it
away from people for a second so that we
can see this clearly
the genes of a spider exist in all of
the spiders
cells incapable of doing anything
exerting any force on the world
whatsoever
except through the spider so you might
say
that actually the body of the spider is
in some ways
in charge of the gene's well-being and
that's true
but if you had a group of spiders
that woke up to the fact that their
bodies were in fact
in charge and that their genes couldn't
force them to do anything
and those spiders decided instead of
investing in
spider ecology stuff they were going to
invest in
um spider hedonism right
something like that so that the spiders
were just doing what their bodies felt
like doing
and not what their genes wanted them
doing which is to spread those genes
then those individual spiders would
indeed be in control they could do
exactly what they wanted but what would
happen
is those spiders that made that decision
would fail to pass on their genes
and two spider generations later
they would be gone and the spiders that
would absolutely well i i would i would
certainly
i'm thinking of a bi-directional effect
obviously i mean it's clear i think
you're absolutely right that
consciousness can make decisions that
are going to put
genetic evolution to a halt
but what i'm saying actually is that we
must do that
if we are to survive but it is i believe
it is the most difficult puzzle human
beings have ever faced
we have to reverse we have to turn the
tables on the genes and we have to
actually say look
we have to confront the genes the genes
awarded us
the most amazing computational machinery
in the known universe they also awarded
us
the ability to pursue and appreciate
beauty to be compassionate they awarded
us all of those things as a means to a
narrow genetic end
a very uninteresting one and the point
is
now that we have consciousness and we do
appreciate beauty
and we can be compassionate and we
appreciate people who have good
characteristics
we have to look at what we're programmed
for and say actually
no the machine is capable of something
honorable whereas the genetic objective
is actually
100 percent identical to the genetic
objective
of every other creature with genes that
is to say
the capacity of a human being is
spectacular it is
unrivaled but the purpose of a human
being is no different than the purpose
of a liver fluke
or an oak tree or a malaria particle
it's to pass on its genes and given that
we can now
see that we don't want to be advancing
our genetic interest because frankly
that's not a defensible goal
but we do honor the things that our
machine is capable of
we have to place those things at a
higher position in the hierarchy
and the critical part the difficult part
is we have to do that
without giving an advantage to people
who refused to give up the genetic
program
as its primary as their primary
objective
god you know i feel like i'm caught in a
modern um incarnation of the arguments
between freud and jung
is that right yes because well but i'm
i'm not playing i'm not playing freud's
role
yes i think i think you are oh terry
there's not an insult
by any stretch of the imagination um and
and but what i hear is
genes as id
well and and and well let me let me just
walk through the analogy sure
and tell me what you think genes as id
and
superego as control mechanism so what
you see in
freud continually is the idea that
base impulses have to be inhibited and
that's actually the primary function of
civilization
and you know the the brain is an
inhibitory mechanism in large part and
so
there's a neurological rationale for
that
we shut off many things all the time we
they're
they're lurking and ready to leap forth
but they're
inhibited but there's two ways of
thinking about such things as the
regulation of aggression let's let's
and that we can work with aggression and
sexuality those
though they come together we started
with rape they come together very well
there
so um do you
inhibit aggression do you inhibit
sexuality
or do you spin them together with
a variety of other impulses and make
them into
like a dynamic and harmonic game
where they have their say where you have
access to their force
but but they're not manifest in a way
that
is incompatible with long-term
reciprocity
and then i would say i wouldn't
underestimate the genes
because i i think that not only do they
code for the aggressive impulses which
they clearly do and the sexual impulses
which they clearly do
but i think they also code for
behavioral patterns that represent the
integration of those into a reciprocal
game
i think we're sophisticated enough
biologically for that
and that's why i think that we admire
that's why we have the capacity to
admire high order ethical behavior
now there might be a bit of a
competition you know that
so that the genes that
that uh control or or bring about
aggression
have been around for so long and are so
primordial and powerful
that the the biology that allows us
to to integrate and to recognize
integration
is of insufficient power to regulate
them
that's a possibility but but i i think
that
our biology i think the biology of
ethics is more sophisticated than
than mere inhibition well so
boy there's a lot to say here one i
think you're hearing echoes
of the debate between freud and young i
don't
think the positions map and
what i would argue is that freud clearly
has something right with respect to
inhibition in some sense human beings
have a range
of behaviors that they are endowed with
genetically
and then the program that they acquire
through
nurture limits where those programs are
deployed
it may turn certain programs permanently
latent
um and my point is
that's a natural process young is
focused somewhere
different right freud is focused on the
inhibition itself and i must say i'm not
well versed in freud but
um with things like uh
the edible complex the electric complex
i believe he's got it dead wrong
he basically bought the job because he
saw
a pattern that he recognized and in fact
it was a
slightly different pattern but we can
return there later
my point would be we have a natural
process
of those inhibitions being
wielded in an ever more sophisticated
way that does
ever better sideline things like
violence society is getting
less violent if you look over a long
time scale it's getting less violent
in terms of your risk walking down the
street more tolerant etc
but that the problem is that that
has functioned as a means to an end and
the
end is a genetic one even though we're
not aware of it
if you look at society any society it
may look
increasingly peaceful but in part its
being increasingly peaceful
on the inside is strengthening it for
battle with other societies on the
outside
and ultimately we can't play that game
forever
right there is no there are no new
continents our weapons are too powerful
we are too interconnected we are all
bound together in one experiment and if
we
continue to allow a dynamic that brought
us here
to rule to govern our behavior
we will extinguish ourselves in short
order so
my point is the genes and competition
between lineages was good enough
to generate all the amazing stuff that's
built into humans
it also generated all the horrifying
stuff it is now time for us to choose
between them
because in some sense we've run to the
end of the tape
we have now gotten to a place where the
game that brought us here
will be fatal we can say that with
essential
essentially certainty um at this point
because of the power of our tools
right 500 years ago a human population
that
uh was foolish could extinguish itself
but it couldn't extinguish humanity and
now we're at the point where a foolish
population can take humanity out
and it's only a french individual yeah
even a foolish individual well
increasingly we're moving to well i
certainly i certainly don't disagree
with that
um that that danger i guess i
i i you know i've always been attracted
to the union
idea of integration of the shadow and
that is not an inhibition argument it's
a it's an integration argument and so i
would say
rather than and i think this is an
important difference is that
there's lots of ways that you can be a
warrior
that are in keeping with reciprocity but
allow
that fundamental motivational force to
still have its
say now let
one of the things that i think
capitalism is i think capitalism is
under appreciated
for its vices
so it's better that warlike men
establish mercantile empires then
empires of war
and so and i think
rather than the whole scale remodeling
of our
group of our proclivity for group
aggression
we need to figure out how to refine and
and
orient it um so
capitalism is a landscape of competition
it's not only that because it's also a
landscape of cooperation and virtually
everything we do is a landscape of
competition and cooperation
but i see for example misguided efforts
to insist that all games among children
be
cooperative as a way of dampening down
the competitive impulse and to me that
that is that's going to make things
worse rather than better now
i'm not saying that that's what you're
what you're aiming at
but it is it look we
we share a common view of this problem
the problem is is that
we've become so technologically powerful
that
our moral failings are increasingly
fatal
okay so what do we do about that well my
my
answer to that to the degree that i have
one is that while we learn to play the
best of all possible games and we bring
all of that evolutionary heritage on
board to play that game
and that's a that's a sublimation and a
sophistication
and and it's it's sort of bj rather than
freud
in some sense yeah i would say uh
i think we're in near perfect agreement
here we have to learn each other's
language about it
yes what i would say is you know
an explosion is a very dangerous thing
but
it's a marvelous thing in a cylinder
where it can be used to do
physical work and so the point is yeah
let's not pretend that we are something
other than we are
but let's take those impulses and
channel them to something
productive and so yes this is actually
that's good because i can bring that
back to my book now because that's what
i'm
that is really what i'm trying to do in
these three books is to say well look
don't underestimate
your downside your capacity for
mayhem but
don't assume that that makes you
unredeemable don't be so afraid of it
that you can't admit to it that'll make
it even worse
and find something better to do
we're jealous and resentful and vengeful
and bitter and all of those things and
i also especially in chapter 11 of the
new book try to explain
why we have those motivations and why
they're so powerful
again to give the devil his due but to
say nonetheless well we have to get
beyond that
despite the fact despite the reasons for
our motives for our dark motives
the thing is we know that we are capable
of marvelous things and frankly
i don't think this puzzle is as hard as
it seems if we set ourselves to it
if we're continually battling over
whether or not it's real
then i i don't think we're gonna make it
but okay so
let me let me offer you a practical
problem i've been talking to
bjorn lomborg and matt ridley on my
podcasts and they're
future optimists in
in within a materialistic framework
fundamentally
both of them insist that things are not
as dire as they're painted but
regardless of that what they do point to
like
stephen pinker i would say is that
we've made tremendous progress on all
sorts of dimensions
in the last three or four hundred years
and there's every reason to assume that
we could continue doing that
over the next hundred years if we got
our priorities straight it's within our
capability
and so you can look at such things and i
think these are hard
bits of data although time frame is
always a problem
um we're there are far fewer people in
abject poverty by proportion now than
there were 40 years ago
and 40 years ago there were much fewer
much fewer than there was a hundred
years ago and that trajectory appears to
be continuing
we can continue to make incremental
improvements in the material well-being
of everyone
by and there's limits obviously and the
economists and the biologists argue
about what those limits might be
but one of the problems with that view
is that it's not
saleable you know
it doesn't have for some reason it
doesn't
have the kind of motive power that
enables people to get on board and get
enthusiastic about it
well i also don't think i i don't think
it's
i must say i have mixed reactions
i'm i'm a fan of ridley's not so much
lomborgs
and i have mixed feelings about pinker's
view there's obviously
some truth in it but i believe
it goes out of its way to miss the
counter-argument
and well it might it it might go out of
its way to mystic
you know even from from a rhetorical
perspective
and you know i would look at that
symbolically i would say look there's a
there's a tyrant and there's a wise king
and they're both there
and if you only look at the tyrant
that's the corruption of society then
you're missing half the story and i
would imagine that pinker would say well
people are looking at the tyrant so hard
that we need to look at the wise king a
little bit more
well i i would take a different approach
to this so i would argue
that things have gotten better
the the pinker pattern is recognizable
but that it is it cannot be indefinitely
extended
and that the limit is that we've come to
a place where
lineage versus lineage competition on a
planet of this size with a population as
large as we have
and the technologies that we've got is a
fatal proposition
almost no matter how it plays out so
in order to take the pattern that has
continued
to this point and extend it indefinitely
into the future
you have to do two things one of them
we've already described
which is you have to take the genes out
of the driver's seat
which is frankly in the long-term
interests of the genes but
genes are too dim to see it right so we
have to take
uh effectively a
something like a buddhist approach to uh
long-term well-being we have to become
very uh
dedicated to the idea of sustainability
and i realize how hard it is to
operationalize an idea like that
but somehow we cannot keep degrading the
planet and
imagining that we're going to
technologically rescue it well i hope
your conscience does that technically
speaking
i mean i mean i'm dead serious about
this because you you just said something
of crucial importance and i think it's
at the core
there's an argument that's always going
on now between
biologists and economists i would say
that they're the two camps
and the economists say human ingenuity
can continually
rescue us from whatever problems are
likely to emerge
and the biologists say well never forget
malthus and it's a matter of time frame
which is the argument you made it's like
well that's working now
you know there's that famous bet between
um
paul ehrlich and simon
and ehrlich wrote the population bomb
yep a very pessimistic book and he
believed at that point 68 i think that
there would be mass starvation and a
terrible shortage of material resources
by the year 2000 and he had a famous pet
with simon who was a genius in his own
right
certainly the intellectual match for
erlick and simon said no
i'll bet you that everything will be
cheaper and people will be less hungry
and simon won the bet
now erlich could say yeah yeah well i
got it wrong by
50 years or i got it wrong by a hundred
time frames
deadly dead yeah so but but okay
we can take time frame serious seriously
i've been taking this idea of an
intrinsic
evolutionarily determined biologically
based
ethic seriously and i think that the
voice of conscience
is the voice of sustainability and
iterability
speaking within and it's not
overwhelming
it's not overwhelming because you have
to sacrifice the future for the present
fairly often it turns out that way right
because you have to
you have to you have to make snap
emergency decisions that might not be in
your best long-term interest but the
long-term interest speaks inside you
agreed and agree but less less and less
well as we have abandoned the mythology
that used to undergird it so as we have
become
more secular why would you say that's a
very interesting thing to say
why do you believe that well i i first
of all the problem
with cultural evolution is that if we
talk about
genetic adaptations you can look at
virtually any creature
virtually any appendage virtually any
behavior
in a non-human creature in its natural
environment and be pretty sure
it makes a good deal of sense right
the stuff that didn't make sense got
pruned away it's not there to see
how it makes sense that's a tough
question but whether it makes sense
not tough almost ever in human cultural
evolution space that is not the case
right we have a huge amount of noise
stuff that will not stand the test of
time that nonetheless
dominates our current cultural landscape
and so we can't go into it and assume
these things make sense so
what i'm telling you is that in my view
the religious mythology was doing
jobs that we don't know some of them we
can
piece together some of them will never
understand what the role of
a particular mythological belief was
but what we have now is kind of an
intermediate level of sophistication
where we've gotten past some of the
religious mythology but without the
wisdom necessary to replace it with
anything that does the jobs that it was
doing
and so we're now screwing up left and
right you know
that's the right way to put it too
because most of this see what to me
what's happened is that
functional mythology has been replaced
by
inadequate ideology and the ideology and
i wrote about this in beyond order
there's a chapter called
abandoned i think of ideologies as
parasites on a fun
on a on a on a religious platform they
have their power the power they have is
because they derive their power from an
underlying mythological
narrative structure but they they only
tell half the story
if that that's that's akin to
that that's an idea that's akin to the
one that you just laid out yeah i think
so although i think you're being
generous to call it all
ideology i'd say some of it's just
idiocy right we've we've
replaced a structure that worked
that is now not viable because it's not
in the environment for which it adapted
but we've replaced it with something
that doesn't stand any chance of working
and we keep
uh you know one self-inflicted wound
after the next and either we're going to
figure out that pattern and recognize
that the function that we're using to
generate the next
level of behavior and culture is a
lethal hazard
or it's going to take us out
so i would say the key if i can go back
to what we were talking about a few
minutes ago
the key to continuing the trajectory
of improvement that has been recognized
by
pinker and ridley at least is to
understand that it needs to be based on
something else going forward that the
limits of the system
that they are recognizing we have to go
through
a a revolution
in the way we
sustain ourselves we cannot fuel it on
lineage versus lineage competition
however what we mustn't do
is either create a stagnation
that causes the human beings to react in
the way that they do
when uh they run up against the limits
of
a landscape a physical landscape or run
up against the limits of
economic growth both of which would be a
disaster so we have to create
a steady state in which we don't degrade
the planet
but we do give the human beings the
sensation of living in a time of growth
that's going to be the key right human
beings when they are
well i want to i want to decorate that
slightly i mean part of the problem here
too
is that i
when you're absolutely deprived having
that deprivation remediated is
powerfully motivating
but as the deprivation decreases the
motivating power of the remediation
decreases and so
i would also say that arguing
for the uh motivational viability
of a more generous material landscape
is also a a game that
is decreasing in its attractiveness
because you know what one of the things
i realized a few years ago was that
um if you're stuck in traffic it makes
very little difference
how expensive your car is
that there's we've we've hit
we've hit the point where
we most people many people have enough
so that having more isn't going to be of
that much utility
and i'm not talking about people who are
still absolutely deprived and i
understand full well that a large
percentage of the population
decreasing though it may be are still in
a state of absolute deprivation
i'm not and they and they're going to be
motivated by the desire
for material improvement for sure but
those of us who are in who are past that
and i would say that's virtually
everyone in north america that isn't
suffering
reasons that material cannot remediate
we're wealthy
we have heat we have refrigeration we
have an
infinite expanse of informational
technology that can all be improved but
the improvements aren't going to make
that much difference
what what's next like what do you do
when you have enough
all right so you try to make everyone
else have enough that's something right
that's something
and it's worth it but even that is a
that's happening right
so i realized something
uh over the last several weeks which is
that there's something that has
bothered me about the way those of us
who um fear
marxism argue against it
it seems to me that we very frequently
say things about
how marxism goes wrong and these things
i would say them very somewhat
differently than most people
but by and large there is some direct
connection
between the attempt to create a
marxist utopia and
starvation authoritarianism
and i think i know what this is and
actually it goes back to the question of
group selection
which is because these systems are game
theoretically unstable because they
punish those who do more and reward
those who do less
in order to get people who
are harmed by that that is to say those
who tend to contribute more and are
therefore punished by such a system
to uh adhere to it you have to threaten
them
right they're unplayable games and you
have to enforce them by force because
people discover they're unplayable
right yeah so that unplayable game i
just want to elaborate that because
you said game theoretic and you're going
to lose you'll know you'll lose a bunch
of your audience because of that
but these are and stop me if i mangle
this but
game theorists are interested in the
repeatability of interactions
and some forms of interactions uh
degenerate with time
those aren't sustainable they're not
good games as you play them you get
bored by them or hurt by them
you don't want to keep playing some
games maintain themselves
and i would say we have an ethic
that teaches us when we're playing a
sustainable game i think that's the
voice of conscience that's related to
the points i made earlier
your main system as it's instantiated is
actually an unplayable game and you gave
a reason is that
you you can't set up a system that
punishes people that are productive
and and and rewards people who aren't
even if some of the people
are only miming productivity and they're
actually power hungry tyrants
you can't clump them in with the
competent people and punish all of them
yep and if you try in order to stabilize
it in order to get
those who are being punished for
contributing not to defect you have to
you have to threaten them so the
authoritarianism follows quickly on the
heels
as does in many cases the failure of the
system to deliver even
basic well-being hence starvation well
and
piaget pointed out quite explicitly
because he was very interested in games
as the basis of morality
that a game that you have to punish
people
to adhere to is going to be out competed
by a game that people will play by
themselves
bingo yeah so what i it's natural ethic
so we make this argument many of us who
have this particular concern we make
this argument or some version of it
here's the argument that i don't hear
the argument that i don't hear but i'm
certain that i believe
and have believed all along is that
equality of
outcome even if you could achieve it is
in and of itself
not desirable and certainly unjust
i would love to talk about that i
thought you might
so my argument is very simple right what
you want
is a system that leverages
well-being in order to generate
uh improvements so in other words
you want the reward that comes from
successfully competing
to get individuals to contribute
to collective well-being and mythology
the mythology of our
economic system is that you're being
rewarded for delivering stuff that's
good
and that's why you're wealthy right now
it happens that our economic system does
a terrible job of this it enriches lots
of people who are actually harming other
people
but in principle if you were
economically rewarded for generating
well-being that would be a good thing
and
it is desirable therefore that we have a
system
in which people who have contributed
more
have earned the right to live better and
people who have contributed less
do not live as well but live at a
respectable standard
and bitcoin people would really like to
talk to you about this i'm sure
they have made themselves hard to talk
to i will tell you but yes well they're
hoping it's incorruptible
you know it can't be gamed as easily and
it's an interesting argument there's
aspects of the argument that are very
interesting
yes they're on to something
they they seem to think they've found
the ultimate uh
solution to all sorts of problems
whereas i think they found a very
promising
avenue but not a solution i remain to be
convinced of that but in any case the
point is
we on the left you will very frequently
hear
that um inequality
is evidence of injustice
yes i i definitely wanted to re return
to that so continue
and this is not the case a system
in which people were armed with high
quality tools with which to compete
in which competition rewarded behavior
that contributed to our collective
well-being
and did not reward behavior where we
harm each other
that would be a good system in which
people would end up living
unequally now it might not be a massive
level of inequality it might be
more limited but nonetheless the point
is
those who would shoot for a system in
which we all end up with exactly the
same amount
are actually setting us up for a very
a despicable and unjust outcome
whereas a system in which the ability to
earn
a higher quality of living is available
to you and you have the tools with which
to pursue it
is a desirable system okay so let me add
something to that
sure okay so it isn't that obvious
when you're talking about outcome and
when you're talking about right now i
don't mean you i mean in general
so like you have an array of talents and
abilities and
and some of those are what you're going
to use to pursue your outcome but some
of them are already outcomes
okay so so it's not obvious what's the
difference between an outcome and an
ability
now you want
to you also want to
if everyone was equal
no one could trade because you wouldn't
have anything to offer me
you have to offer me something i don't
have
now you might say the fact that you have
something i don't isn't an outcome but i
already said that
what exactly constitutes the outcome is
blurry
it's arbitrary now
all you have to bring to the world is
what is
unequal about you and so unless
and you'd think that people who push on
the diversity end of things would
recognize that above all else
and so to by by forcing equality
you actually destroy what everyone has
to bring to the table to trade
and that's a terrible thing because well
because you punish them then for the
best thing they have
that's one terrible thing but the other
thing is you deprive
everyone of the opportunity to benefit
from everyone bringing
what's unique about them to the table so
i would say
there's a there's a terrible
contradiction between diversity
as a value and equality of outcome as a
desire
those two things aren't i don't see how
they're logically
commensurate that's a very interesting
point i i really
i really like it um that in effect
uh our collective well-being is a matter
of the
creation of wealth through the exchange
and the exchange
inherently requires an inequality
right yes and you even work for the
inequality because let's say
you're only as good as everyone else at
some at everything
well then you're going to go out and
educate yourself like mad about
something
until you're now a marketable commodity
and you should and so you're making
yourself
you're you're increasing the amount of
inequality as a consequence but that's
actually a virtue
not an advice another way of putting it
is that
in order for all of the jobs
to get done that make us collectively
robust and well-off people have to
arbitrage
things that are under valued in other
words if there is a dearth of computer
programmers
then it is your desire to get ahead that
might cause you to go into computer
programming
which is the force that ensures that
there are enough computer programmers in
the next round of the game
and if you don't have that motivation
because everybody has been slated
for an equal outcome then the point is
there's no telling what you'll have too
many of and too few of in the next round
because there's no reward for figuring
out
uh which thing is uh is
is is uh well worth it there's a punish
there's a punishment for
being exceptional because your
exceptionality
is exists in violation of the principle
of equality
yes it's uh i mean it's uh it's the
harrison bergeron uh dystopia
and so anyway i didn't want to um
drag us too far down the road here but i
do want to say that i think both of
these arguments against
anything uh marxist
must be on the table right not only
does it devolve into something uh
authoritarian
and ineffective at feeding people but it
also wouldn't be desirable even if it
didn't
it would be horrifying and
so i want to put that as a counterpoint
to what i was arguing for before which
is
in order for us to continue through the
next several hundred years let's say and
to continue to enjoy
a high quality of living we have to
retool the objectives of the system
so that they give the human beings the
somatic sensations
that they need we have to feel that we
are living in a time of growth because
we will be less violent if we feel
the sensation of growth i think your
point about
integrating the
[Music]
dangerous components of the human psyche
with the productive
components is probably key to this as
well in other words
and in fact we can see many examples of
this right so
for example if we look into the past
before widely available birth control
for example
before widely available birth control
women
were wise to avoid engaging in behavior
that might cause them to have to raise a
child alone
because that's a very expensive mistake
to make
the fact of women being careful about
that made
sexual relationships with women scarce
they had a high bar to them
and when they had a high bar to them
that created an awful lot of motivation
for straight males to achieve things
right and so the point is okay we
pulled the plug on that system sex
became common
people are now much more or straight
males are much
less likely to have incentive to
participate in the system so maybe we've
substituted a pure financial incentive
for what was once a romance incentive
right so that's one example another
example might be
the the case of the way
once upon a time corporations used to
deal
with their career employees
right who came in at some rung of the
ladder
and every year or two uh was
awarded a bonus or you know a raise and
an increase in the benefits that they
had access to
and that creates a kind of sensation of
growth
even if the economy was stagnant
um and so in any case what i'm arguing
is that there have been
things in the past that functioned so as
to create the correct
uh structure of incentives for a person
so that they had meaning and direction
in their life so that
basically by following um a normal set
of
impulses they ended up uh likely to
uh contribute and then what we've got
now
is effectively well very much to the
title of your book
chaos where following one's impulses
is very likely to lead you to spend
tremendous number of hours
playing a video game that does not
contribute positively to the world
but costs you has an opportunity cost
with respect
to what you will learn and achieve
so what do you think about this i mean
you can
i'd like you to answer this personally i
mean
you've made some costly decisions in the
last few years
and they've had benefits they've had
benefits as well but they've also had
costs
my sense is that
as we face an increasingly complex
landscape and the consequences of our
actions echo
ever more powerfully
around because of the technology that
the best place that we can start
investigating to find out what the path
forward might be
is in
more careful attention to
the voice of i said this already
conscience
does that seem to you to be because you
said something abstract we need
we need this landscape to replace
to to rectify the flaws in our current
landscape
but getting from that from where we are
to that point is a very
difficult proposition you know i've been
criticized in my thinking because of my
undue emphasis on the individual you
know
especially by people i would say people
who are more on the left who
who maybe view things at a systems level
more
readily well what about the role of
government what about the fact of
inequities in society
um shouldn't you be concentrating on
movement at that level and i think well
all of that's changing extraordinarily
rapidly as it is
there's no doubt that there's action at
those levels that's necessary but that
doesn't seem to be what's particularly
germane at the moment
because i don't know where i don't know
where else we can turn for answers i
also turned to the past you know i
i made the presupposition which is
something you laid out earlier that
you know if if an animal species engages
in the behavior consistently
you might start by assuming that there's
something useful about it
even though you might not understand it
i made that assumption when i was
looking at religious belief because it
was clear to me and still
is as a biologist that human beings have
a religious instinct
we have the capacity for religious
experience
and so that it so so dismissing all that
out of hand
because you're scientific actually seems
to me to be a contradiction in terms
you know if you're a physicist perhaps
and perhaps not but if you're a
biologist well no wait a minute you
you run into the problem of darwin
immediately
human beings have a religious instinct
why is that
well is it a spandrel i don't think you
should be allowed to define spandrel's
post-hawk
you know i can't figure out why that's
useful therefore it's an evolutionary
dead end
perhaps not well the spandrel argument
uh it's funny i was just uh writing
about it a little bit uh this morning
but uh the spandrel argument is a red
herring your argument is exactly
correct for and in fact i generated
a four-part test for adaptation
um to escape the spandrel's argument
many years ago back do you want to
define spandrel just so that they're
going to lose people on on that one sure
yeah spandrel
is an architectural consequence
of placing a dome on
columns they're these sort of roughly
triangular shapes
and there's a famous set of them
in saint mark's basilica in venice which
stephen j
gould and richard luonten used as the
central metaphor
in a paper that they wrote in 1979
which argued that evolutionary
biologists
were getting ahead of themselves and
making up lots of stories to
explain why this that and the other
trait of creatures was
adaptive when in fact they didn't have
the logical basis to make that claim
now i'm not going to go into the whole
set of counter arguments but
it's a nonsense argument on their part
there's like a
a grain of truth and then a whole lot of
fiction stacked on top of it
which was interestingly deployed
uh both uh gould and luanton
had marxist sympathies and there was
this sense
that so this was the era in which
sociobiology
was taking off and people were realizing
um just how powerful evolutionary
thinking was in explaining human
behavior and marxists don't like this
idea
at all they fear it because well it
means that human beings aren't
infinitely malleable
or that we have a nature and and that
that has to be contended with
that we have in nature and that we are
not inherently
equal right because in order for this to
be a consequence in order for behavior
to be a consequence of evolution
um more effective behaviors had to
out-compete less effective behaviors
more effective people had to out-compete
less effective people
and so that's it runs counter to the
marxist sympathies
and so in effect this paper based on
these spandrels
um argued that uh evolutionists
didn't have the evidence to claim
adaptation except very rarely
so the other right because a phenomenon
could be the side effect of something
that was selected for and
it hadn't been selected against yet so
it's there but it's not because it
it evolved so to speak right so if you
were standing looking at
and maybe i'll i took some pictures when
i was in venice recently
and i took some pictures of these
spandrels for the purpose of talking
about them on youtube and
anyway so these these triangular spaces
that are left when you place this dome
on top of these
columns have been filled with mosaics
uh in the central one they've been
filled with mosaics of
the four evangelists and so their point
was you could look at these and you
could say
that the purpose of the spandrel is to
house these mosaics when in fact the
spandrel is an accident and the mosaics
are just something that
opportunistically was placed there
um so why did that come up here
we were talking about oh you were
talking about
religion and whether or not it was
justified to imagine that it was serving
some
adaptive purpose by virtue of the fact
that human beings seem to have a
propensity for
religious belief and i 100 agree with
this argument i have made this argument
myself
the cost of religion to humans is so
great
that it must be paying that and much
more at least historically
in order for it to have been a feature
of every important civilization
so that argument is completely uh
robust as far as i'm concerned
now i'm trying to recover there was a
thread
that uh was the central argument that
you were making has to do
with oh yes
you're right glad you got it sometimes
it's a
it's a mire of weeds but uh okay
the point was this you are sometimes
taken to task for being overly focused
on personal responsibility and
neglecting
the uh collective well-being functioning
of society level
now as luck would have it that was
actually on my list of things to talk to
you about today
because um the
here's what i have learned as a uh
a lifelong liberal who
has now gotten to an age where wisdom is
beginning to dawn
is there is something about the personal
responsibility argument
that is uh absolutely essential and
there is a reason
that it looms so large in the minds of
so many
high quality thinkers in spite of what
it doesn't do
the reason is if you're going to advise
somebody or
some small group of people on how to
approach life it's the slam dunk winner
right it actually works you do have
power over
yourself and how you interact with the
world so if you encounter a system
that's very unfair
you can complain about the unfairness
and you have a very low chance of
affecting it
at all or you can say well it may be
unfair but
i'm going to play the cards i've been
dealt as well as i can
and that's something over which you have
a tremendous amount of control so i
think there's a
way in which the just in terms of return
on
investment there's almost no return on
the investment in
complaining about a broken system
there's tremendous returns
to be had well it's especially true if
you're not already competent
and seem to be competent maybe you have
some
ghost of a chance of changing things if
you
are competent and are seen to be
competent but before then
um you can break
things but building them that's pretty
damn
hard and so and you can work
locally and then you have some chance of
success
and you can find out what is under your
control and then maybe you can turn
yourself into someone who can
make cautious systemic adjustments and
have them be for the good rather than
than for harm whereas whereas
if you take the other approach and you
say well the system isn't fair
and i'm going to change the system but
you don't invest in your own competence
then a you're unlikely to fix the system
but even if you do
you still don't arrive in it competent
and so you're still going to be out
competed by people who did invest in
personal responsibility so
in some sense it's just a loser of a
position from the point of view of
an individual's uh allocation of their
time and effort
on the other hand let's say so
you know i first started thinking about
this when i encountered uh
a number of um black conservatives
who had initially i didn't understand
why there were black conservatives
because it seemed like the system is
unfair to blacks i know this to be true
and so um putting the responsibility on
the individual didn't make sense to me
but then i realized this that i've what
i've just said to you that
from the point of view of helping people
this is the winner
as the argument goes and the other one
doesn't even work
but here's the problem with it let's say
that you
you get the attention of a number of
people who are deciding between whether
to complain about the unfairness of the
system or invest in personal
responsibility and you convince them
that personal responsibility is the best
answer
okay they will do better
they will do better at somebody else's
expense they will out-compete someone
else and it may be that you haven't
increased the amount of wealth in their
quadrant of the system at all
and so while you've given them good
advice for not ending up
uh at the short end of the stick um you
didn't
solve a problem it just shifted where it
went
so there is i think though that would be
i think that would be more dangerous if
personal responsibility was directly
associated with
like socioeconomic success as a as an
infallible marker of that responsibility
it's partly why i constantly try to
concentrate more on
on ethical behavior and grounding
responsibility in that because i think
that
if i don't think that you have to gain
at the expense of other people if you
play the game properly i think you can
gain
it's hard and i'm and it's it it's hard
to do this
but you can you can play the game so
that the people around you benefit
at the same time you do and that's
actually a better game anyways even
for you and i i know that can run into
zero
sum problems but no matter what you do
it can run into zero sum problems i
think it has the best chance of
minimizing those zero-sum problems over
the long run
you know so you play the game and you
don't cheat
so if you're going to be a plumber then
you're a good plumber and that's good
because
no one wants their basement full of
sewage it doesn't hurt anyone you
out-compete some of the plumbers who
aren't doing so well but
so i agree with you completely you can
generate some wealth by
increasing your capacity which means
it's not zero-sum you ultimately may run
into a zero-sum
uh game in which the fact is some
somebody's gonna be the loser
part of the reason that i wrote the
second book beyond order
was to state something like look
try to be successful try to be
responsible
but if you find out that you're being
successful in a zero-sum
game and your success is at the expense
of someone else
then you change the system
perfect that's why it's beyond order
it's like because
your point is something like well if the
game is unfair and you're good at it
then you just get better at exploitation
it's like right right of course systems
can be corrupt and then if you're a good
player in that game
then you're the best at being corrupt
but that's the situation where you have
an
ethical obligation to move beyond your
responsibility and to adjust
the game that's how it looks to me
right oh no we've landed in exactly the
same place that's that's the point
is that the the problem is that the
system
is effectively in breach of contract
which doesn't say anything at all
about whether or not your best move is
to complain about the system or invest
in
right i would say it's also an eternal
truth
that the system is in breach of contract
that's an existential reality
it's always now to a greater or lesser
degree let's
because there are systems that are
completely unplayable and
there are systems that are relatively
playable but the the idea that your
conscience should be bothered by the
corruption of the system is like
absolutely true
but that doesn't mean that you should go
making in cautious changes as a
consequence of resentment
right so now the present
looks so insane from this perspective
that you and i appear to share
right where we are now educating
children ever
younger in obsessing about uh
defects of the system many of them
imaginary right
rather than giving them competence in
fact we are demonizing
the very acquisition of competencies
there perfect that's exact so
that's that's something that needs to be
broadcast
everywhere i think that the what's that
the pathology that that's that's at the
core of the culture war
is an attack on competence itself
it's an attack on competence the idea of
competence as well
that's why the the critiques of
meritocracy emerge or
that's at least part of the motivation
for that and everyone you know you can
say well look do you rise according to
your merit it's like
partly okay partly and
to and corruption
reduces the correlation but
to say partly and to admit to the
existence of some corruption
is not the same thing at all as to say
merit itself is a corrupt idea
right that's a completely different set
of propositions with completely
different outcomes totally agree
and so we are constantly in this battle
where if we say
anything in defense of the idea of merit
or meritocracy we are understood to have
claimed that we
live in a meritocracy and what's more a
perfect one
and then this is used to to
remove any impulse towards the
acquisition of capacity
and to do this to children is so
terrible
it's terrible yes it's um the worst of
all possible things you can do to
children because you punish them for
their virtues
right you're not giving them brain
damage you're giving them mind damage
you're damaging their minds well i
looked at what happened in boston this
week when
so a number of the um
schools for the gifted were my
understanding is were closed down
because of racial inequality in their
makeup
and i thought well it's it's obviously
um an undesirable
it's obviously problematic
but why should i assume that the motives
of those who shut down the gifted system
is the remediation of racism rather than
an assault on the gifted
because it's them that suffer
immediately for it
right now you know maybe that's unfair
but
but i ca i can't help but think that
what we are seeing in the guise of
virtue is an assault on the idea an
assault on competence
the the thing is competence presupposes
value and value presupposes a hierarchy
so if you admit to competence you admit
to a value hierarchy
and differential ability and that is
flies in the face of equality
so so
i completely completely agree and
the obvious answer of course is
irrespective
of how unfair the system is you should
invest
in your own competence you should make
use of what tools you have
and then we collectively ought to
democratize the tools as well as we can
because society is clearly best and it
is the morally only acceptable thing
that's even the only self-interested
thing ultimately i would rather that you
were more competent now if you're
head-to-head in a competition with me i
might let resentment
you know uh allow me to desire
your destruction but all things
considered if you're competent
well great then you're going to offer me
something okay so
we could agree perhaps that there is an
element of the war
on competence that's the pathological
end of this culture war that we're
seeing and we should also say that
there's no doubt also a fair bit of
attempts to uh rectify
the terrible consequences of power-based
inequality
right so the good is intermingled with
the bad but we have to pay attention to
the bad
then another question would arise would
be and i don't know the answer to this
at all
if we're seeing the rise of something
like a war on competence
why are we seeing it and why now
yeah that's a tough one um let's put it
this way
i do not know of any evidence
that it is our global enemies
seeding this but they could hardly have
done better
right were they to try to get us to
sabotage ourselves they could hardly
have done better than to get us to
demonize our own competence
and to sabotage our own children i mean
the the thing that i can't get over is
all right if we woke up
and came to our senses tomorrow
how long would it take for all of the
nonsense to clear the system and for us
to get back to the level of competence
that we were headed towards i mean
this is we're talking about you know
the arguments have gotten particularly
stupid in the last couple of years
but the overarching degradation of the
system by those who didn't believe
incompetence in the first place
goes back decades and has
had a tremendous effect and you know
what the bridges aren't falling down
yet not in large numbers but that's by
virtue of the fact that they were built
by competent people
and uh they don't require you know
yearly
maintenance and this is going to catch
up to us
it is time for us to to return to our
senses
and get back to business right quick or
we are going to leave
ourselves vulnerable to people who care
so much less
about freedom and about uh justice than
we do
do you i'm trying to to to
understand again why this might be
occurring i mean one possibility brett
and
this would be something interesting to
consider at least briefly is
like do you trust
your sampling of the data that indicate
this
is happening you and i are in a
particular position
and and we share it
we're going to be much more sensitive to
that kind of information
and we're going to be provided with it
preferentially by other people
now i look and i see especially what's
happening in the education system
for example i saw the uh
some curriculum material for anti-racist
math
um claiming for example that getting the
right answer was
indicative of white supremacist culture
domination and
so is showing your work ridiculous
propositions but then you know i don't
know
how widespread that material is i don't
know how influential it is
i'm i don't know who to trust to report
on those things to me
and i don't know how to escape from what
might be the bubble that i'm in because
of my particular
situation so
thoughts on that oh many a
there's no good way of doing the
analysis because
what we have is sampling bias everywhere
and what's worse it's not even
consistent because we don't know
how the algorithms are modified when
they're changed in what way they're
changed
you can't it's a moving target on the
other hand
the material you're referencing
with respect to mathematics showing your
work
focusing on the right answer etc being
somehow associated with white supremacy
that is uh that was
funded by the gates foundation i know i
know so that tells you something and
it's backed by apparently backed by
many influential school boards and i've
seen that
the same ideas pop up in the tweets of
of
of public school superintendents right
commonly
where generally one of the things that's
so amazing about that i saw
one of the superintendents in michigan
had posted um
an image of a blackboard with some of
those propositions on it and there must
have been
400 comments some hundreds of comments
about that all negative yeah and i
thought well if i was the person that
posted that
and i got 400 negative comments i'd be
so shell-shocked i wouldn't be able to
leave the house for like a month and i
mean that
i mean that you know so i think well
how can you post something like that and
then get 400
negative comments with nary a positive
one because that was really the case
and not think maybe i made a mistake
do you do what do you do do you spin
into a conspiracy theory at that point
and say well you know these are
this is a codery of people that are
targeting these ideas and it's not
representative of the general population
i i have no idea what hoops you'd have
to jump through
as you will recall all of these
tropes about white supremacy and
evidence and merit they all involve
these tricks to prevent you from
discovering the truth
right so the idea that to ask for
evidence of racism
is racism is a booby trap it's a kafka
trap
and what it means is that somebody who
believes this stuff and then gets a
whole lot of pushback
has five categories with which to
dismiss it right so
whereas you or i might
hit a particular sensitive note and say
well
that's flack over the target right i'm
pretty sure i got close to something
because
of the reaction i got well that requires
a certain amount of care that you do it
only honorably only when it's justified
but somebody else who regards any
negative but i also
like i also look at proportions you know
like if i put up a youtube video
right i actually attend to likes versus
dislikes i read through the comments and
you know i'm not happy when when five
percent of them are negative you know
and that's a that's so far thank god
that's about as high as it gets some of
them are very vitriolic that are
negative
and they certainly affect me but i'm i'm
very
sensitive i believe emotionally to to
that kind of
quantity feedback as well as quality
well i mean that's partly how you keep
yourself oriented in the world isn't it
of course but you know you're actually
looking to calibrate something
you're a scientist and you're looking to
understand what the actual information
is
and to you know sort the the signal from
the noise
somebody who's interested in advancing a
position might
have a mechanism for dismissing the
signal um
but the answer to your your first
question which i believe
is very important and i'm glad you asked
it
about well how reliable because i
inhabit a position a position in the
universe that might cause me to see
all of that evidence and i might be
misunderstanding how ubiquitous it is
the fact is there's lots of evidence
that it's ubiquitous for example
um in the u.s and i assume in canada
every parent i know with kids in school
is facing that school
now passing on disinformation
about the nature of american history
about the relations between people of
different races
school names are being changed this is
taking place
in every school of ed it is apparently
taking place as much as i never would
have predicted this
it is taking place across corporate
board rooms
right and the thing that i yeah for evil
capitalists they're sure not very good
at defending themselves they
have no idea no imagination for what
kind of fifth column they're allowing to
emerge
well how pernicious that's going to be
what little information
i have uh about what's really going on
there it sounds like
they are actually being persuaded of
this nonsense
which i find well i think the like guilt
a lot of it's guilt it's like guilt is a
very powerful motivator especially for
people who are
essentially ethical you know when you
might say well corporate leaders aren't
essentially ethical it's like no no no
just hold on a minute if you look at
what predicts success
in business it's intelligence and
conscientiousness just like in science
so it's it's intelligence and and and
hard work
slash ethics that doesn't mean everyone
who's successful is ethical but
you can't point to success and say well
that indicates a lack of ethics
unless the system is entirely corrupt i
think it's guilt it's like well it's
guilt and it's
failure guilt failure to pay attention
to pay attention especially to the long
term
underestimation of lack of knowledge
about what's underneath all this but
then again you know maybe that's just my
paranoid perspective
and yours too because we see we see
these things well that's the thing you
see these things and you think no
there's something lurking there
um well at the very least i think what
we can say is this
it is entirely possible for a person to
get the wrong
impression about how ubiquitous a
movement is or how far its influence
stretches
but that we can check this in a number
of places
it appears to be every major
college and university it appears to be
almost every corporation it is every
tech platform
it's certainly every faculty of
education every faculty of education
and and that's not good it appears to be
nearly every uh high school
it appears to be driving
the ascendant political party in the u.s
so how many of these things have to be
true before we simply accept that for
whatever reason
this movement is incredibly powerful at
the moment
that this is not our imaginations this
is not us
looking at a biased sample and and
overreacting to it
the evidence is this is um
it is controlling many of the levers
that dictate the way resources are to be
distributed
and that i think anyone who doesn't see
the pattern is a fool not to be
frightened
well that doesn't help me escape from my
bubble does it
[Laughter]
um well i don't know i uh yeah i mean
there's an awful lot of power just
simply between the democratic party
the tech platforms oh we didn't even
mention uh
all the um major
news media well there are a couple of
exceptions obviously the wall street
journal is an exception
um fox news is an exception and you know
certainly exceptional stories show up in
mainstream
news media but again the preponderance
appears to have been
persuaded of this so uh
i think to the extent that one can peer
outside the bubble and see the same
thing that one sees from within the
bubble
it looks like this is um this is
as as concerning as we would tend to
suspect
well that's too bad i would rather be
wrong and this would be an illusion
than to be right and to be and for it to
be the current reality
i i wholeheartedly agree i i also think
optimistic as i am about the possibility
of what we could all accomplish over the
next hundred years
i don't think we're nearly at the end of
this
because it seems to be accelerating to
me and
and the claims get more and more
outrageous
and the amount of resistance gets
littler smaller and smaller
you see you see some exceptions to that
i mean um
a lot of journalists have abandoned
the new york times and have hit substack
and they seem to be eking out an
independent existence there
and so that
looks potentially promising that sort of
thing
well i think it is promising and i think
you know hopefully we'll we will see
more of this
um the uh
in some sense we are going to need
parallel institutions
if we cannot retake the institutions
that exist we're going to need parallel
ones in order to fight back and
ultimately
right exactly well that's working isn't
it that's another example of what's
working
i agree which which makes it worrisome
that uh
we now see an instinct towards
censorship and uh
the policing of viewpoint on the yeah
well it certainly made me nervous
i've had conversations on my podcast
recently
that ver made me very nervous
and you know i've been hit enough times
i would say so that
i don't have quite the resilience that i
once had and
um it doesn't seem to have stopped me
from doing this but
it certainly made it harder to do
um you did you see what happened to dr
seuss today
oh my goodness yes i did um and
you know it was obviously only a matter
of time
but uh i it's hard to imagine that we're
here
i mean it's not that it's not that
there's nothing to the claim obviously
there are some early cartoons that are
disturbing but
you know it's not like he defended those
cartoons he apologized for them
you know he appears to have uh to have
grown up and the idea that we're going
to deny
children the cat and the hat because in
the
20s dr
seuss made unfortunate cartoons
it's preposterous and i would also say
well if only those who are sin free or
allowed to contribute we're going to be
in real trouble because
you know my sense is that creative
people are just as flawed as everybody
else
and that's flawed a lot or maybe even
more flawed sometimes because you know
they can be
creative in their flaws um
i think that's true i also as long as
you raise it i just
want to say one other thing about dr
seuss
which is the cartoons that are troubling
are um
[Music]
they are real and
the disturbance at them i understand i
feel it too when i look at them
but i also know that human beings
are wired to caricature
members of other populations and
that's not a good thing but we've also
gotten over it
right the fact that you find disney
cartoons that characterize
or that caricature uh chinese people and
blacks and everyone else
the point is we have understood that
this is bad and we've stopped doing it
and that's honorable and to go back and
punish people from the period before
it was understood to be bad as if they
were living in the present
is obviously absurd just as it is absurd
to pull down
statues of abraham lincoln because
you know he did not have a modern view
of racial equality
right it's nuts we just we have to stop
behaving this way but
i don't know why i'm telling you that
you know that as well as anyone
so well you know that was good
yep that was good um sorry it went so
long but i gotta say
uh it's been uh incredibly enjoyable
and i certainly hope you wore me to a
frazzle
all right well uh i look forward to our
next conversation whenever that may
happen thank you so much for
joining me on the dark horse podcast
jordan your book
you want to hold it up again
[Music]
uh here we go beyond order um
and it is available as of today which is
mark second
i recommend everyone get a copy number
one in australia
all right hey while we've been talking
it may be number one in other places
canada canada all right excellent
well i'm looking forward to reading yes
and it says beyond order not destroy
order good right glad you clarified that
okay
okay jordan thanks so much bye bye
be well
[Music]
you